it used to be that
a lot of parts of brooklyn were all
italian italian neighborhoods you grow
up you know everybody on your block and
um then if your last name had mick in it
you were taking your life in your hands
yeah well
there's some bad parts of that as well
right but there's also like um i feel
like we've lost that sense of community
are you guys good set up
what are your names i'm james james nick
james and nick and you're saying you're
visiting here texas visiting yeah from
uh i'm from brooklyn new york and james
where are you from i'm from rambek new
york we're the only two conservative new
yorkers are you really
no you don't know where you're from
brooklyn brooklyn yeah my whole life i
actually find that as you get out into
the borough of a lot of the
working-class areas particularly like
long island
it's often surprising how right-leaning
a lot of them are no there's there's um
a conservative group of people in long
island i'd say and then some parts of
brooklyn where i'm from but when you get
into uh manhattan um
very rare i would say i like to see um
and you definitely can't talk about
certain ways that you feel about things
but now
first off let me ask you so you're from
brooklyn we were talking earlier you
said yeah italian american italian
american giant
and then well i could guess by the beard
for crying out loud i'm all in about at
some point too maybe in your 40s
probably you're back just so you know
that's yeah you're not wrong it's not
it's not it's called father time and
it's coming for you and you're uh you
said greek young greek you got olive oil
in the blood yeah you got olive oil well
you both do so uh all right so you said
you're you're more conservative so my
question here today is fourth of july
sounds like your plans are you've been
traveling right you were you said you
were for a friend's wedding in florida
kind of traveling across the south um
the question we're just asking people is
you proud are you proud to be in america
yeah proud to be an american we were
just talking about how we feel like a
lot of people don't really reflect on
fourth of july as much anymore at least
we don't but as i was thinking about
this before we came over it just got me
thinking about how the fourth of july is
all about freedom and how i'm kind of
concerned that the government is
putting more and more restrictions in
our lives like yeah
like the roe v wade thing that just came
out we don't have to talk about whether
you're pro or anti that but just that i
think the answer to a lot of these
problems is not the government it's not
bigger government it's within the values
that we ourselves hold right and i think
the government is trying to force their
values upon us yeah i think that happens
sometimes i i would uh you know with roe
v wade i would
i find it ironic it's one of the few
areas where the supreme court said we're
actually removing our power and giving
it to the states yeah we're not going to
regulate from the bench states can do
whatever they want i think a lot of
people don't really know that they think
it's like a ban it's like no you can
still you can go as extreme as you want
in california colorado we're just not
going to step in at all it's not a
federal government issue what about you
prior to being american 100 um i was
talking to your buddy over there before
um and a big thing that i wanted to
bring up is and i i've had the privilege
to go to other countries before yeah and
i feel like a big part of really
appreciating america is going to other
countries experiencing them and then
coming back and really i mean you get
that home feel right like my home and
things like that um and i've never lived
anywhere for an extra long period of
time so maybe my opinion would change
based upon that where have you visited i
visited of japan before and i love japan
japan's like one of my favorite
countries to ever go to um and it's just
a different it's really like a different
world there it's hard for me to put into
words because
you just kind of experience more of
their culture whereas america we're like
a melting pot of all these different
cultures which is its own beautiful
thing but it's it's different right so
um you have a little bit of a loss of
i feel you have a loss of that like
group um mindset right like you're
saying before like i'm a brooklyn
italian it used to be that a lot of
parts of brooklyn were all italian
italian neighborhoods you grew up you
know everybody on your block and um then
if your last name had making it you were
taking your life in your hands yeah well
there's some bad parts of that as well
right but there's also like um i feel
like we've lost that sense of community
that i have seen in in other countries
where they've had that community but at
the same time we've opened up um our
country right to all these great people
from all different places around the
world and we've built kind of a newer
community and i think that's something
that is really unique to america um and
everybody
like he was saying before where you kind
of take these holidays that we have for
granted like people like today from
school or work and things like that yeah
um but they really mean something so
when when you have this time off it is
something that you should reflect on and
think about all the people who died to
kind of get us to where we are right now
right well it's interesting that you
bring up you know japan because a lot of
times that japan comes up and they talk
about gun control you know very good
they don't allow you to
but again you're talking about a country
that really was it's based on
imperialism right and it's based on
submitting to that so submitting to a
ruling class and it is very homogeneous
like you've discussed i mean some of the
laws there are what americans would
certainly consider incredibly racist
like even if you look at some of the
tenant laws um and here you were talking
about that yeah yeah yeah yeah
if you look into moving there you
probably saw it oh this might be a
little bit tough
they'll have too much of be it you know
uh but you're italian american and
you're a greek american that's right and
you probably wouldn't find as many
super tightly knit italian and greeks in
italy or greece
yes
they're a little more uh yeah well even
within italians themselves right there's
always been that north and south kind of
a few they make fun of in shows like
sopranos and sicily the moors we've all
seen true romance i'm actually half
sicilian sorry okay
all right but
yeah no but definitely i agree uh so
you're proud to be an american would you
say um and like you said i think people
confuse that question with is america
perfect that's not the question no um
but do you think that would you still
consider and i agree with you you know
concerns about uh
some of the directions we're heading in
in the united states but would you still
say it's uh the greatest country in the
world yeah based on the other countries
i've been to definitely like i've been
to to france into iceland
not that those are bad countries but i
definitely feel the freest here oh yeah
yeah we went to a gun range the other
day it was really cool we actually met
this kid from england who was really
nice but he was shooting a gun he had
like had no idea what he was doing
because you can't shoot guns over there
right so well it's very makes you
appreciate these things technically you
can but not in the way that we have it
here for self-defense i mean i don't
know if you saw i was raised in canada
we were talking about that earlier and
our prime minister just said you know
canadians unlike americans they they
understand that you do not have the
right
to uh firearm for self-defense so you
said you don't have the right to defend
yourself
um and look there's good and there's bad
right of people being allowed to have
firearms
but it does depend on your perspective
do you believe that we have the right to
defend ourselves with firearms and
there's you know there's
responsibilities that come with that or
would we rather have a prime minister
say no you don't why so i think in
regards to that i think a lot of people
feel it's like oh that would never
happen like you never will have to use
that for self-defense and i think
maybe they're right but the point is is
that it's a possibility right um and i
think to remain a free country we should
still have that right obviously you can
go down a whole rabbit hole of like
background checks and things obviously
certain things should be into place and
people mixed feelings on that um
but that being said at the end of the
day like
true freedom is the freedom to both
protect yourself and express yourself
yeah right well while we were driving
through like
on our trip from florida we were driving
through like alabama mississippi
louisiana in the woods and we just kind
of noticed how arrogant it is for some
people from like these big cities to
talk about like oh we don't need nikkei
47 like you don't even know what you're
talking about right you've never been to
a place like this where you're 100 miles
from civilization it's like yeah you
need to call a copy
from deliberately the government to take
a step back people need to
be able to govern themselves a little
bit more yeah or certainly people living
in alaska or um you know a good example
is i don't know if you're familiar with
uh you know like wyoming they have a
bear problem do they like a brown bear
problem which they didn't really have
before they were just as a hilarious
video that i've shown that where there's
a grizzly bear and a dairy queen like a
drive-through it's going through nuts
and uh a big reason is they're not
allowed to hunt them uh but that's also
a federal thing where they step in and
look we have a problem here we need to
hunt themselves well you can yeah
there's two hundred thousand dollars for
every tag tell them so who gets to do it
the ultra wealthy and so it ends up
being more of a problem they're not
endangered they're encroaching they
become comfortable with humans and so
someone in new york may not understand
why someone in rural wyoming needs
something pretty damn powerful it's also
bull crap like they're not trying to ban
hunting calibers that are far bigger
more dangerous like if you're from new
york i'm guessing you probably haven't
had a ton of experience with guns not no
but the laws like are weird right so in
new york city
a little bit different yeah new york
city the the laws are weird where it's
like
it's super super super strict in new
york city which makes sense whatever
it's a city um but in long island like
you could just go and buy a shotgun
rifle right right versus and i mean you
gotta live there you gotta have your
license gotta prove you there there is
some what like background checks and
things like that but it's way different
from new york city where you gotta go
like fingerprinting and yeah well and
handguns are basically oh hangouts i
mean now it's gonna change because we
just saw that yeah exactly in new york
city you have to basically go through i
have a friend um who i think he waited
like four or five years to even get uh
his hand going yeah i guess i'm 25. so
he started like 21 and 20. okay it took
him a long time yeah yeah and then like
and he just got it like two weeks ago oh
really yeah so to have to carry a
handgun or just to own a hand to i think
just to own one oh you can't carry it
forget about it well that'll change now
the supreme court yeah yeah because the
supreme court said if you can't do that
you can't tell people that they can't
own but i mean just like buying one
getting your license like that whole
aspect of it yeah no i i know i have
friends who live in new york and it's
very different um
let me ask you this uh it's interesting
that you mentioned you've been to france
you've been in denmark and i was raised
in that time oh iceland sorry there was
a previous uh gentleman who said he
wanted to move to denmark
um it's funny because we've had people
say that those countries are better you
know and uh that uh
denmark iceland are often the nordic
countries which i don't know if you
notice not a lot of people who look like
you there it's pretty homogeneous i'm
sure you notice when you're in iceland
you know what i mean yeah that i mean
all white blue eyes blonde here yeah you
could use it to white balance the
cameras right here uh
and uh they don't have the same what did
you mean when you said that you didn't
feel as free because i know what it was
when i lived in canada obviously it's a
little more difficult to describe but
france
i was there for a study away in college
and it just seemed like
the police were not there to protect us
it seemed like they were there to make
sure a mass terrorist attack did not
happen it was like these military police
walking around in groups of like tanned
with machine guns right i would like
walk down the street they'd be like a
burned out motorcycle it just seemed a
little like a different vibe yeah yeah a
little more a little more wild i think
i've also even heard you say in one of
your videos that you can't compare like
how you can compare sweden to like the
bronx right there's certainly how you're
gonna compare you know denmark to the
united states yeah it'd be more often
compared to rhode island and that's not
a joke no seriously yeah yeah we're just
we're so and that's part of the reason
too while we're visiting stuff too
because it's like our country is so huge
and you kind of forget that because
everybody on a micro scale you're in
your own life right now and you kind of
only see what's around you so going back
to what he said about us driving you see
like these houses kind of in the middle
of nowhere right where somebody who's
worried about protection for themselves
in the middle of nowhere is completely
different if somebody's worried about
protections like my house is attached to
the person next to me you know right and
it's like you're in like a you're at
least in some sort of neighborhood
community type aspect where if somebody
sees something they might say something
if you're in the middle of nowhere you
got animals you're saying like bears and
stuff yeah it's like it really it's
really made me appreciate the the layout
of the united states i think our trip
because that's where driving it just
seems so arbitrary like oh we're in
we're in alabama now or in mississippi
and it's like two miles later like
what's the difference but yeah you
really do need these these states where
everybody where they have different laws
because there's different needs yeah
it's yeah you can say that in school but
until you really visit yeah you can see
that it's it's the truth like your
lifestyle you know what's interesting
here i hate to ask you guys to move in
close i know you know the whole rivalry
italian greeks but it's just hard for me
to get the microphone going no but um no
you're absolutely right uh it's that's
why each state is sort of its own petri
dish you know i mean they need to have
unless it's enumerated they need to have
their own powers and this is something
that doesn't really exist outside the
united states but what's interesting to
me is you said okay you studied abroad
france iceland you've traveled quite a
bit
uh
and i wonder if a big differentiating
factor is that you've probably maybe
experienced more of the united states
because a lot of people your age they
traveled abroad and i just liked it so
much more than america
uh why do you think why do you think
that is i think it's a romanticized view
of things
i don't think they really sit there and
look at the policies of the country
living and maybe they're
they're thinking about what feels good
now what not what feels good in 20 years
like right what feels good in 20 years
is going to be uh well i don't know i
don't that's the right way to put it but
no i think the governments are have a
lot more control over people's lives
over there so i'm trying to say i agree
with the the romanticization of that
whole aspect of going abroad to other
countries right you get people with cool
accents and yeah the thing too is like
the land is so beautiful and all the
other places and you're not really
to that respect though you're not
thinking about
actually living there you're kind of
just you have this imagery of you go and
you see like these beautiful waterfalls
and mountainscapes and but what's it
like to raise a family there take care
of if you have cattle and then like you
know what i mean it's a whole how are
you gonna interact with your neighbors
do they like it are they going to have
what's going to happen if you have a
problem with them like right that's all
part of real world life if you have kids
where are they going to go to school and
think like you're not thinking about
that you're thinking i'm going to go
have like daiquiris
and hang out at the beach it's like
that's not a life that's maybe like two
weeks out of your life yeah and by the
way the uh the american lesbians that go
over there the island of lesbia lesbos
they're in for a rude awakening they're
not necessarily welcomed with open arms
oh really i don't even know
better looking over there it's not the
same people who shop for their shirts at
bass pro i think um i think the way i
would summarize it is and being raised
in montreal which is very european i
don't know if you've ever been i mean if
you're new york you probably should go
visit my show if you're like i want to
get my european fix without you know
paying for a ticket you can go visit
montreal it's uh it's far more like
europe than it would be like new york um
old beautiful cathedrals churches right
historical buildings i think when people
visit a lot of these countries like you
said they're looking at it through
colored glasses they're going to
experience
and this is true the beautiful things
that were in the history
but america is at least as an idea
trying to be a place of the beautiful
place that he is
i think maybe that's kind of what you're
saying not only in 20 years but okay
today now what is it not what did they
do centuries ago um because it's very
different you know i mean they even talk
about you know look the roman empire
yeah it's not the same as italy today
you know even though it would be a silly
thing to act like it is it doesn't mean
they don't have beautiful things to
offer but you know historical like
artifacts and things like that exactly
but it's a different world that we live
in so what let me ask you this uh
what is
what is it that you love most about
america i believe this is kind of a
feel-good thing for people to you know
not want to swallow a sword with all the
negativity and media what do you love
most about the united states of america
oh lis my cousin vinnie i'll start with
you
oh man
uh
i want i want to say something that's
like really unique too but it's it's
because everybody's gonna say i love
where i'm from i feel like it's hard to
find somebody that really hates where
they're from because it's their home
yeah but i i mean
like
i did i was born in detroit and then
raised in montreal that's where you
couldn't get out quickly enough yeah
yeah honestly like and then maybe this
be my only personal experience in
america but i love the familial um
raising of how they say it takes a
village to raise a child yeah right and
i've truly experienced that with all my
family um and it's something that
in my experience the united states is
i don't i hope it's not unique but i i
love the fact that everything is from my
life has been family oriented people
supported me after my whole life and had
given me the freedom to choose whatever
i wanted to do and go with my life and
what i wanted to do in my career and i
feel like in other countries where other
people grow up maybe they don't get that
where they say oh you have to be a
doctor you have to be a lawyer you have
to be whatever whereas i grew up in a
family where we didn't come from money
my my parents um didn't go to college
really like family's very poor great
grandparents grandparents come from
italy um but they always wanted the best
for their children yeah and they made
sacrifices to make sure that it could
happen um and at the end of the day they
just wanted me to be and of course they
yell about them yeah you have any idea
what i did so you could be a little
exactly always hold that over here oh
yeah of course no but it's strong family
units and a lot of people overlook you
know italian-americans there's this
generation right they have
italian-americans coming in
irish-americans yeah jewish-americans
and of course
not to mention the history of
african-americans and by the way the
african slave trade which of course
contributed to it
italians very very strong family units
and a very strong sense of community
i don't think you get a ton of that
everywhere else in the united states
but that is something that for sure i
think is
is a great part of the united states and
you know like i'm talking about italian
man we think oh in america we go
italians and greeks are very similar
very very different when you actually
look at the history throughout europe um
as a matter of fact there's quite a bit
of feuds if you look at through the
history people get to be friends here
what's your favorite part about the
united states
oh favorite part yeah what's your
favorite fact that we cannot we're not
supposed to be able to be imprisoned for
political dissent disagreeing with
people i think
that when
today in the area of the era of the rise
of censorship yeah people assume that
their party is always going to be the
one that is making those rules right i
think that is very very flawed yeah this
dangerous idea i like the idea that we
we aren't forced to exist
for like our ethnic group for the
government we we can exist to serve
ourselves our families our friends if we
want yeah and create the life that we
want to with and take
we have a lot of opportunities that we
can just take right to do those things
we aren't prevented from doing that well
i think actually as you know someone if
you look at greek history it's a perfect
example of that because people here and
your professors go look at these greek
philosophers and sure that's absolutely
right but also look at the fates of some
of those philosophers look at the
persecution that some of them experience
as well so a lot of these people once
they started thinking outside the box
too much they didn't have the first
amendment that we have here this is the
first country to really do it that way
people kind of tried to we don't have it
in canada um it's not just political
dissent you know we have a good friend
who was actually put before a tribunal
and went to the supreme court for a joke
a stand-up comedy joke and it wasn't
even racial it wasn't even uh
about women it was about a kid who did a
make-a-wish foundation on the canadian
version of american idol and sucked
singing it's brutal but it was funny
and we experienced that in canada and
that is something i think that coming
from abroad i really experience actually
final question we've spoken with a lot
of people today
and um what's interesting to me is the
people who hesitated and said like oh i
don't know if i'm proud to be american
i'm trying to go through my memory bank
yeah all
upper middle class white people
uh and a lot of them would answer
because of racism
but
all the black people who we spoke with
including people who were homeless or
were homeless said i'm absolutely proud
to be american it's the greatest country
in the world
and that by the way not too dissimilar
from italian americans if you look at
history and italian americans how they
were sort of persecuted and viewed and
marginalized
why do you think there's that divide i
do find it pretty interesting that a lot
of the american white liberals who speak
for the marginalized don't actually
listen to what they're saying
so
that honestly a lot of thing everything
comes down to marketing i think right
and a lot of the times it's it's what
everyone's being shown for the most part
i'm not surprised italian would say that
you guys always present it like hey look
this is what you got to do you tell you
tell them you don't tell them this part
but no you're it's pretty much like that
you know like even um
i don't want to like say anything when
it comes down to say like even the cova
vaccines right for example um
i'm a proponent of vaccination i'm not
anything like again right but the way
jenny mccarthy the way stuff was handled
it almost was kind of like the mafia in
a little bit where it's like
you either get the vaccine
or you you're going to lose your job
like you know but no we're not going to
make you lose your job that's the
freedom to do that the teachers couldn't
imagine like wait [ __ ] you're going
to force them to take an injection we
can't do that come on we have
limitations but not to get off topic
like point being i think a lot of it is
everything that's that's shown to you so
if if you don't it's almost like the
difference between reading a book and
actually living life right you could
read about something and think like you
could be a huge um like a college
professor for example like i did i went
want school originally for mechanical
engineering but i don't do that now but
um even in there like a lot of it was
all theory so theorized right where some
professors some of them had worked and
then they retired and became professors
but some of them they've been going to
school their whole life which is don't
get me wrong like they're in their
specific topic they're very well uh
versed right in whatever you're talking
fluid dynamics or um thermodynamics
whatever um but when it actually goes
into practice of like what you're doing
um a lot of times real world stuff
happens right where you go
the reason i'm laughing is because you
were talking exactly like a
stereotypical italian with your hands
and you were sitting you're standing
like a like a statue of plato it's just
literally it's like a greek statue
italian what i'm worried about
mechanical engineer i don't want you
building our planes like this ball
bearing [ __ ] and then all this stuff
like that well that's because we had to
you know we had mickey over there doing
it and he just he broke the engine
that's why uh flight 46 yeah it's not
it's that real world experience man that
you just you can't read about you can't
like i mean
there's obviously proponents of news you
got to know what's going on in the world
but
like i said before like macro and micro
yeah it's like you got to look at things
in into perspective and to really get a
feel of the world around you it's really
on that micro scale and you got to do
your part and there's only so much yeah
i think for
first-hand experience what do you think
it is that there's that divide i'm sure
you experienced it there even in upstate
new york yeah upper middle class
primarily caucasian liberals saying well
this is what happens to marginalized
community and then they say well yeah
that's actually not our issue i just
think people as a whole have a tendency
to be discontent with where they are
especially in places that are good they
always want to believe something's
better the grass is always greener like
that's not my idea i think that's just
that's human nature right and unless you
unless your value system lends itself to
being appreciative of what you have and
really looking at that and comparing it
to what's what you could be in like you
could be in china where if you go
outside of your apartment building
you're in prison for 20 years because of
the cove lockdown you could be in canada
where you can't even cross the border
because you're not vaccinated it's like
wait a guy i don't know how anybody
could could be unappreciative of america
we have definitely our flaws but it's
the best country in the world we
literally had a guy today who again sort
of the other side of the aisle was
saying you know i went to china of
course you know i don't like the
government but really it's just great i
recommend you go to the culture it's
great i'm like well hold on a second if
the government can arrest you that is
the primary driver of their culture
right now you can't and then just what
do you mean
you just think it's beautiful because
you like you like the food like have you
seen what happens with the wiggers like
we sort of with other countries pick and
choose and go oh there's this beautiful
aspect of this chinese culture there's
this horrible aspect of american culture
you go yeah but
most of chinese culture today
is horrible it's a gross abuse of human
rights and i think it's picking it's
being like a cafeteria sort of liberal
in a way where they can choose who you
are yeah yeah and they take the best of
other countries and the worst of america
and that's what we've noticed here today
it's been uh
it's been actually really uplifting to
see that a lot of people are like no
it's flawed but it's still the greatest
country in the world um like we could be
australia i used to want to go to
australia but now i'd rather not be in a
prison camp so i stayed here exactly
isn't it funny that's how they started
as a penal colony and now they're going
back to it yeah so
everything old is new again
shackles are the new black in australia
all right thanks guys i know it's hot
out here so i appreciate you guys taking
some time oh man i really appreciate it
and uh let me know if you go there and
do those wings
hey if you like this video hit that uh
notification bell
up there uh or subscribe or share this
right isn't that right dave smash that
like button and share it where would you
wear it what are you wearing there
that's nice oh this is uh i found it in
the trash yeah also known as
your shirt
crowdershop.com which is where you can
go and support and uh
we
we have overs we keep the overstock in
the trash except for people who are
little yeah he says i haven't earned it
yet because i ain't grown all the way by
the way if you find hunter biden's gun
in there just let it be